cuando estudiamos la glucólisis y la
conversión del piruvato en acetil coa
luego entrábamos al ciclo de krebs que
también conocemos como el ciclo del
ácido cítrico y vimos que en algunos
pasos se producen directamente atp es
verdad tenemos la producción de atp pero
también dijimos que estábamos reduciendo
algunas moléculas de n además en línea
de h y luego dijimos que el nh puede
oxidarse también y la energía de dicha
oxidación puede utilizarse para generar
otros atp es verdad podríamos generar
más
a tps en este caso y aunque nh es el
personaje principal digamos en este caso
también hay otras coenzimas involucradas
por ejemplo la coenzima q que podemos
ver aquí y bueno lo que quiero platicar
en este vídeo es el proce es todo sobre
el proceso mediante el cual obtenemos
esa energía del nh y esencialmente la
conocemos como fosforilación oxidativa
muy bien y el principal jugador cuando
estamos hablando de la respiración
celular y la fosforilación oxidativa en
este caso sería el nh que el nh en el
proceso de oxidarse en n además digamos
éste puede oxidarse en n además que
podemos observar que tiene una carga
positiva entonces podemos observar que
es lo que pasa en esta reacción desde el
punto de vista del nh que se está
oxidando y recordemos que la oxidación
es pérdida de electrones así que podemos
obtener también un protón aquí tenemos
y también vamos a obtener dos electrones
verdad y esto es lo que ocurre cuando el
nh se oxida en nd así que vamos a poner
esto aquí obtenemos una reacción de
oxidación aquí tenemos una reacción de
oxidación y en este proceso se puede
liberar mucha energía y el receptor de
estos electrones verdad sería digamos
vamos a poner la reacción así vamos a
poner la reacción tenemos 2 electrones
también vamos a tener dos protones aquí
tenemos dos protones y en realidad aquí
uno podría pensar que es media molécula
de oxígeno gaseoso pero en realidad todo
esto lo podemos pensar en moles verdad
serían dos moles de electrones dos moles
de protones y medio mol de oxígeno
gaseoso y esto nos da un molde de agua
cierto así que podemos pensar que el
oxígeno es el receptor final de dichos
electrones verdad bien y en realidad al
oxígeno les gusta
justamente oxidar
de ahí viene la palabra oxidación verdad
aquí al oxígeno lo que podemos decir es
que le gusta reducirse verdad es decir
le gusta acaparar electrones entonces
decimos que el oxígeno se redujo aquí
ocurre que el oxígeno
oxígeno se redujo de lujo
ahora bien si directamente
transfiriéramos estos electrones digamos
que se liberan del nh verdad si los
transfiriéramos directamente al oxígeno
entonces se liberaría tanta energía que
no seríamos capaces de asimilar la no
podría digamos servir para para hacer
trabajos útiles así que el proceso de la
fosforilación oxidativa se trata de
hacer esto en una serie de pasos y lo
hacemos transfiriendo estos electrones
digamos pasando los de un receptor a
otro y cada vez que lo hacemos libera se
libera energía pero de forma más
controlada y puede generar trabajo en
este caso el trabajo es bombear protones
a través de la membrana y luego el
gradiente que se forma se puede puede
usarse para generar atp pero ya
llegaremos a ese punto más adelante así
que vamos a adentrarnos un poquito más
en este punto que acabo de mencionar y
aunque no vamos a entrar en todos los
detalles esto solo es para darnos un
panorama general de lo que es el proceso
entonces estos electrones
ir pasando de un receptor a otro por
ejemplo pueden pasar a la coenzima q a
la coenzima q después de pasar por la
coenzima q pueden ir al citocromo se
vamos a poner al citocromo
muy bien y puede continuar pasándose
hacia otros receptores hasta que
finalmente puede llegar a esta parte
verdad a esta parte donde los electrones
pueden ser aceptados por el oxígeno para
poder formar agua verdad y ahora
recuerda que en cada paso de esta
digamos de esta desde el paso de
electrones verdad tenemos liberación de
energía aquí tenemos liberación de
energía acá tenemos liberación también
de energía muy bien y esa energía se usa
para bombear protones de hidrógeno a
través de la membrana verdad y ese
gradiente es útil también para la
formación de atp así que vamos a
adentrarnos ahora un poco en esto último
vamos a dibujar una mitocondria vamos a
movernos hacia la derecha y aquí vamos a
pintar nuestra mitocondria verdad aquí
tenemos la membrana externa y ahora
vamos a pintar una pedazo digamos vamos
a pintar un poco la membrana
digamos más o menos algo así verdad ahí
tenemos los pliegues de la membrana
interna verdad que conocemos como
crestas y sólo para hacer un poquito más
claros vamos a poner que es cada cosa
aquí tenemos la membrana externa la
membrana externa acá esta sería la
membrana interna ésta es la membrana
interna y al espacio digamos comprendido
entre estas dos membranas este este
espacio que tenemos aquí se le conocen
justamente como el espacio inter - o
verdad aquí está el espacio espacio
interno
ínter membranoso membranoso muy bien y
puedes notar que tenemos otro espacio
verdad tenemos el espacio que está
dentro de la membrana interna este
espacio que tenemos aquí ya éste se le
conoce como matriz muy bien esta es la
matriz de la mitocondria muy bien y de
hecho es aquí en donde se lleva a cabo
el ciclo de krebs verdad que es en donde
se produce la mayor parte de los nh es
así que voy a poner este pequeño ciclo
para representar que aquí se lleva a
cabo el ciclo de krebs y no sólo se
produce la mayor parte de los nh sino
que también hay otros se producen otras
con enzimas que ya hemos mencionado
verdad por ejemplo mencionamos el fadh 2
verdad
efe efe de h 2 luego se utiliza para
reducir a la coenzima q verdad y
producir q h 2 y luego está participa en
la fosforilación oxidativa y de ahí que
en realidad puedas fijarte en cualquiera
en particular yo me voy a centrar en
cuba- ch2 bueno aunque mejor vamos a
centrarnos sólo en nd porque en realidad
atraviesan procesos digamos similares de
hecho fadh 28 h 2 en realidad entran más
adelante en la cadena de transporte de
electrones y de hecho no producen tanta
energía pero aún así son útiles para
producir atp ahora bien ya dijimos el
ciclo de krebs ocurre en la matriz de
nuestra mitocondria pero ahora vamos a
hacer un acercamiento a la membrana
interna vamos a hacer un acercamiento a
este pedazo vamos a hacer un
acercamiento verdad y qué es lo que
vamos a observar bueno en realidad es
una membrana verdad y como toda membrana
está formada por una bicapa de
fosfolípidos muy bien vamos a poner esa
bicapa de fosfolípidos y la voy a hacer
suficientemente amplia para que quede
muy claro qué es lo que está ocurriendo
aquí
a poner otra
series de
aquí de las cabezas verdad de nuestra
capa
tenemos las cabezas y tenemos las colas
cierto entonces no voy a pintar la cosa
de todos sino así simplemente aunque sea
un poco espaciado y ahora vamos del otro
lado entonces esta es la bicapa de
fosfolípidos porque es como cualquier
membrana verdad y también vamos a tener
unas proteínas que atraviesan esta esta
bicapa verdad aquí podríamos tener una
primera proteína verdad tenemos una
proteína que atraviesa esta bicapa en
realidad estas son enzimas que de hecho
son complejos proteínicos que facilitan
la fosforilación oxidativa vamos a poner
otro par de estas proteínas no sé cuál
se exactamente la geometría de estas
pero sólo para que quede claro vamos a
ponerlo así vamos a poner una tercera
una tercera por acá verdad vamos a poner
una tercera y vamos a extender un
poquito más nuestra bicapa verdad vamos
a poner un poco más de estas que vamos a
extenderlo aquí también muy bien lo que
ocurre es que cuando tenemos nh tenemos
aquí nh y cede digamos los el don a los
protones y electrones entonces se
convierte en línea de más verdad esto es
lo que vimos en esta reacción de
oxidación y estos electrones digamos van
a ir con otro receptor por acá y luego
con otro y luego con otro y así
sucesivamente van a seguir nuestra
cadena de transporte de electrones y a
medida que la energía se libera se
emplea para bombear y para bombear
protones de la matriz digamos la matriz
es lo que se encuentra del lado
izquierdo aquí tenemos
matriz vamos a escribirlo bien aquí
tenemos la matriz de la mitocondria muy
bien y los protones son bombeados hacia
digamos hacia el espacio intervendrán
oso que se encuentra del lado derecho
verdad aquí estaría la matriz y del otro
lado tenemos el espacio intervendrán o
entonces a medida que los electrones van
yendo de estados de energía más altos a
estados de energía más bajos hasta
digamos llegar al agua como vimos en
esta reacción entonces se va generando
un gradiente de protones verdad es decir
estamos aumentando la concentración de
protones del lado derecho es decir en el
espacio intervendrán uso y entonces todo
esto en realidad es energía almacenada
verdad ya que esto es en esencia un
gradiente electroquímico y con toda esta
carga querrán alejarse mutuamente y
quizás quieran ir a este lado digamos al
lado de la matriz en donde hay una menor
concentración de protones es decir a
donde hay menos carga positiva
vamos a tener una concentración más alta
en hidrógeno del lado derecho por eso
digamos por difusión tenderán a ir a
zonas con menor concentración por
ejemplo nuevamente hacia la matriz
verdad ya que aquí habrá una menor
concentración de hidrógenos y este es el
momento adecuado para usar esta energía
para producir atp y la forma de hacerlo
es utilizando un complejo proteínico que
se le conoce como atp sin tasa entonces
voy a tratar de esbozar un dibujo de la
atp sin tasa digamos tiene como una
estructura aquí tiene por aquí como una
especie de eje y tiene otra estructura
más o menos de ese estilo en realidad la
estructura de la atp sintasa es
fascinante y está atp cintas atraviesa
la membrana y de hecho tiene una
estructura mecánica muy bien hecha más o
menos se ve así aunque después te voy a
enseñar un mejor diagrama y lo que pasa
es que esta está atp sin casa permite
que estos protones de hidrógeno sigan
digamos fluyendo
en dirección contraria a su gradiente
electroquímico verdad y de hecho hacen
que este eje gire vamos a pintarlo así
hacen que esté gire a medida que los
protones van viajando hacia la matriz y
bueno hay que recordar que todo este eje
no es liso toda la atp sin tasa en
realidad no es que esté hecho como de
metal verdad como como ocurre en las
máquinas en realidad todo esto está
hecho de aminoácidos verdad entonces no
es liso en realidad se ve bastante más
complicado ya veremos una imagen más
adelante verdad y no hay que olvidar que
esto en realidad está hecho de
aminoácidos y lo que ocurre es que
tenemos digamos a dps alojados por aquí
déjenme pintarlos por ejemplo aquí
podemos tener a dps alojados por acá y
podríamos tener un grupo fosfato verdad
en realidad hay tres sitios en donde
puede ocurrir esto verdad donde tenemos
el pp con un grupo fosfato verdad
y digamos hay otro tercer sitio que no
voy a pintar por acá pero bueno lo que
va a ocurrir en esencia es que sigue
cambiando la conformación de la proteína
y lo que ocurre es que embona el grupo
fosfato con el atp tomando digamos
energía para sellarlo y formar al final
el atp entonces cuando el atp está
digamos ya formado este ya no se une al
sitio activo y le permite liberarse
entonces aquí tenemos la liberación del
atp verdad entonces casi podríamos
pensar esto como si fuera una turbina
cierto en realidad el agua
digamos entra como si entrara por aquí y
luego esa energía se utiliza para
generar electricidad
aquí lo que entra son los protones de
hidrógeno y este movimiento rotatorio se
usa para unir el fosfato con el atp
verdad entonces de esta forma obtenemos
el atp y esto es en realidad algo que
está ocurriendo en nuestros cuerpos en
este preciso momento incluso para que
pueda yo hablar en este momento necesito
energía y que se generen los atp es
ahora para tener una mejor apreciación
de qué es lo que ocurre voy a mostrarles
una imagen más precisa de lo que es la
atp sin casa
aquí lo tenemos y con base en este
diagrama aquí digamos vamos a pintar el
espacio internet brand uso sería esta
parte de arriba esto sería el espacio
inter membranoso y si ese es el espacio
internet planos o entonces aquí
tendremos la matriz verdad esto que
tenemos como en gris es nuestra bicapa
de fosfolípidos es decir es nuestra
membrana vamos a poner aquí algunas
las cabezas y colas aquí tenemos
una capa aquí tenemos la otra verdad
esta es la membrana y la membrana
interna de la mitocondria que en
realidad podría ser un pliegue de la
membrana es decir podría ser una cresta
verdad entonces los protones de
hidrógeno se acumulan en el espacio
intervendrán huso aquí vamos a tener
acumulación de protones verdad de este
lado y estos se acumulan debido a la
cadena de transporte de electrones luego
fluyen en dirección opuesta al gradiente
electroquímico verdad van fluyendo
digamos en esta dirección
hacen girar este rotor y permiten la
creación de atp es por aquí entonces
digamos vamos a tener por aquí a dp voy
a ponerlo aquí vamos a tener a dp que se
va a unir con un grupo fosfato se va a
unir con un grupo fosfato y esto nos va
a producir
ese es el final digamos vamos a tener
atp y esto es fascinante en realidad
esto está ocurriendo en las células de
tu cuerpo en este mismo momento en
cierto sentido es lo que permite que tu
que tu realidad sea posible verdad así
que espero que tengas una mejor
apreciación de todo esto ya hemos estado
hablando bastante tiempo sobre la
respiración celular verdad ya hemos
hablado de la glucólisis por ejemplo
hemos hablado de cómo se produce el atp
directamente de la glucólisis o también
cómo se produce atp en el ciclo de krebs
verdad aquí tenemos la formación de atp
en el ciclo de krebs pero en realidad la
mayor parte de la energía proviene de la
reducción de estas coenzimas por ejemplo
n además en nh o por ejemplo también
estas de por acá verdad porque luego en
la fosforilación oxidativa se va a
oxidar estas con enzimas verdad y en la
cadena de transporte de electrones
podemos usar la oxidación del nh para
bombear
hacia el espacio intervendrán oso y
luego se les permite entrar de vuelta a
la matriz verdad haciendo funcionar a la
atp sin tasa que es 12 más o menos aquí
verdad la atp sin tasa y que esto al
final pueda producir atp que es la
moneda energética de los sistemas
biológicos